when they when they're teaching a lot of
the stuff which
borders on inappropriate sexual behavior
you think the police are actually going
to do anything there's laws they have to
they have to literally if you're a child
within that teacher
or she was a workshop they do the
workshops now justine was her name
um i can't think of her last name but it
was justine something
and she's the one that did both of the
workshops she was one that showed the
pornography to the 16 year olds at the
dalton school in new york city and she
was the same one who showed the cartoon
to first graders about masturbation
about how it feels going to touch
themselves let my
child in the first grade have seen a
cartoon about masturbation and i'm going
to go
if you literally showed a child on a
playground a cartoon not masturbation
that's disseminating sexual
uh material to a minor yep point blank
if you go to the police and you follow
report there's no law saying to police
while
it happened in school so you can't do
anything as it was taught to them and no
wow the second one parent has the
courage to do that
right and a teacher gets arrested this
crap is going to stop because he's going
to be like uh-uh let's go
look do you know what i'm saying i'm not
getting arrested like you're you're
you're a sexual offender
in my opinion justine register as a
sexual offender justine
fonte i think renee she should be in
prison from a month ago
columbia prep students and parents reel
after class on
porn literacy i can't say the words i
can't say the words that were being
taught it's like this was a class that
taught
if i say the words youtube will maybe
even take this video incestuous porn
like like incestuous yeah in class and
the parents there was no permission slip
that went out it's disgusting first
kindergarten that was a 16 year old but
she also was the same one who did the
first graders
the thing is these people have that was
like that was a cartoon about
masturbation for the first graders
about how it feels good to touch
yourself and it was talking it was a
cartoon
i they give these people tight the title
of teacher and that it's similar to
having the title of president
if you win the title because you got
picked then you get this
but the real teachers are like on the
internet like jordan peterson he makes
videos no one has to be there
people choose to listen and learn but
these people are people are stuffed in
and forced to listen to this person with
a
with a badge that says something that's
what they've realized
that these kids are a captive audience
that and and
they were do you remember uh when the
lockdown first started they started
doing remote schools
and one of the teachers was caught
someone recorded this where they were
like i'm worried the parents are going
to find out what we're teaching their
kids now
yeah and that's the thing and the
government understands this and again
the irony being everyone is calling
people you're literally hitler
you're literally not well what was not
to youth okay what was not to youth
it was a way to plug them into a system
to get to get the children on board into
the system
to believe everything that the
government believes well that's the
exact same thing that's happening right
now that it didn't change because it's
happening on american soil
they obviously understood for six hours
a day they have your children
there and now they're rinsing the
schools of hard academics they don't
math is racist that's an initiative by
bill gates looking look it up bill gates
started an initiative saying that
white's
that math and encouraging children to
get the right answer is a form of white
supremacy
um he's calling it equitable math and
now he is pushing for the curriculum to
stop teaching kids to get the right
answer
and just allow them to tell you how they
got the wrong one and they should still
get a 100.
make your child dumb check this out
check this out we went to uh
we were talking about this yesterday i
went to a skate park over the weekend
and
skate park's notorious for kids being
punk rock fighting with security guards
vandalizing property and yet the
graffiti was at the skate park
black lives matter trans rights or human
rights that was the graffiti and
i started laughing i'm like that's like
an amazon.com like big bold thing when
you go on it's like
it's like it's like a it's a it's an
organization it is mainstream pop
culture
the embassies fly the flag and little
kids think they're being rebels
by adopting a message that is used by
u.s embassies and walmart.com
right that is youth indoctrination and
they don't get it because these kids
they're kids right
and the problem is that the adults are
crazy right so the adult those are
totally looney tunes right so the
problem is
is twofold it's that there's some weird
olympic event to be the most woke parent
like i was so accepting and loving
because my child is a non-binary species
and
it's amazing right that's like the new
thing i'm like i'm such an
amazing parent my child the non-binary
mermaid
and then you couple that with the
education so that's reinforcing that
okay so how is it possible that i went
to school it was no
thing is non-binary we didn't have a
single child that was non-binary yes
we didn't have it right so it's
obviously not natural for all of these
kids popping up now doing videos saying
i'm non-binary because none of us had
this issue when we were growing up and
none of the people that i went to school
with
now that's even an option have opted
into this right because it just wasn't
even presented to them right it wasn't
presented so it's not like
oh they were just suppressing this and
then now that it's a thing i have all
these kids that i graduate with that are
like i'm i was always non-binary no it
was like
tomboys like i was a tomboy when i was
in fifth grade this is why
we got we gotta be careful about saying
it's just critical race theory in
schools no it's
critical theory in general it's like the
marxist oppressor versus oppressed
it is critical gender theory it is
critical race theory it is critical
white studies
it is the idea that everything is bad
you're the bad guy i'm always right no
matter what happens
you know uh you're the problem right
like why whirl the dice why roll the
dice people are
i would never send my child they're
getting the internet three-year-olds are
on the internet so we're talking about
these technocrats keeping their kids off
the internet
and there's a reason because when a
three-year-old goes on and looks at like
cartoons but then it turns out it's a
youtube cartoon of hitler dancing with
bugs bunny and you're like what is this
and they're learning about like why it's
okay to why gender doesn't matter and it
hates raising your children the internet
is raising children and a good example
of this like in the mainstream
is so dwayne wade right he has a child
who has come out as a trans
i don't know how i don't even know what
he had a son
who now identifies as a daughter right
and i remember watching the story and
you know him and gabrielle union came
out and you know she's super woke and
they were like so saying how like brave
and encouraged they were and like this
is just who this person was right
but then i remember seeing the photo and
this is before
he had declared his gender as being a
woman
or a girl and seeing a photo of
his son in a crop top you know at a
pride parade
um and with long long like cardi b like
fingernails right
okay well that obviously wasn't who this
person was where'd you learn
the crop top and the long fingernails
right that's social social construct
that's a social construct right so you
can't tell me you know you can say
people have a natural affinity
okay wanted to hook up with the guy i
wanted a girl but you didn't learn long
fingernails right so where did your
child learn that with my question dwyane
wade how did we start with the crop tops
and the long nails because that's not a
thing
and the answer of course is going to be
the internet because if you're on
instagram today that is a culture you
know
not even the kardashians um what's the
kylie jenner you know the lips the
fingernails all the stuff it created an
entire culture of this
and you're a basketball player i know
how aggressive that schedule is i know
that it is hard to be a parent and be on
the road playing
um x amount of games all year and
so what was happening while you were on
the road and he's you know in a split
home as well so it was with his you know
with his his mother
um it's likely that the internet helped
to raise your kid and this is how we got
here but rather than have that
conversation which is much more severe
and hard to have
we're just going to go ahead and allow
your you know 12 year old at least then
12 year old to make a permanent life
decision okay
three dwayne wade three uh his trans
daughter
knew her identity since she was three
years which is scary because i babysat
three-year-olds who literally think
they're mermaids like i've had a
three-year-old in a tub
she cried and screamed into a temper
champion because she told me she was a
mermaid
and i cannot imagine giving credence to
that and saying you know what
sleep in the bath tonight because i am
sorry and i
can't wait to go to tell the other
parents how amazing and woke i am
because i'm accepting you as a mermaid
i'm pretty sure when i was three
and my mom asked me what i wanted to be
this is a true story i said a pumpkin
i like that yeah it was like i was just
like a little kid and that was like a
story my mom would say
people would be like what does he want
to be and she's like well he said
pumpkin i really wanted to be a power
ranger
yes yeah i still kind of do but you know
you know he's joined the marines
nobody recognized my power ranger skills
which power ranger
um that's a very good question that's a
very good question by the way
in the retrospect how racist yeah the
yellow one's
asian the black ones black the white
ones white the pink ones are girls
oh
like mighty morphin power rangers was it
it was it was
so weird though like wait how did how
did the original power rangers happen
where they're like sitting there like
let's make the yellow ranger
asian yeah i know it's so great it's so
great
i know i know i'm sure they're already
canceled we just have to look google it
i'm sure someone realized that 20 years
later
it goes back to like the 70s there was a
show that was like the first one where
there was like five people in different
colored outfits that would come together
to form like a big creature and then
they became voltron that it became the
power rangers yeah
power rangers i don't know that original
show i don't watch i don't remember what
it's called i have no idea
okay yeah voltron yeah voltron was the
80s version they were all these cat
machines they would ride around and then
they'd form this giant guy who had a big
sort
of big robot 42. okay it was hot 86.
i like the green dinosaur remember when
um
mario lopez was he was on someone's show
yeah and he said
i don't think three-year-olds know that
they're trans you know what show that
was
what was it the candice owen show that
was your show
he got in trouble he did he came on my
show and
it was what was so bizarre and mario was
a friend of mine and like
so bizarre like we just didn't go there
like it was like sort of just
it was such a non-question it wasn't
like i was pushing him it was just sort
of like
what's it like in hollywood now because
it's the woke olympics and he was very
nice and he just said like
you know for me personally like you know
i understand when you're adult do what
you want but just let kids be kids
yeah you know and they it was funny
because it was like two months later
after the interview
and then suddenly like mario lopez is
trending and there and everyone listened
to it was like he literally said
as nice as possible like hey let kids
grow up
and um they were in to cancel him and
yeah
he did apologize but i will say it was a
very like
it's always the same apology copy and
pasted where like you have to say it
and you know i was bummed that he
apologized but also
not bummed because he's a great he's a
fantastic person really a fantastic
human being i think him and his wife
are such an example of what it means to
just be a very present family i'm very
impressed by them
and just imagine everything you have
being gone in a moment unless you do
this
and so yes i i would i would stand by my
guns but when you have three small kids
it gets harder and it gets harder and it
gets harder right here but think about
the future for those kids
100 true but he's probably he's on the
other side thinking of the future for
those kids right so it's like whatever
schools they go down maybe they go to
private school they have a house he's
got a mortgage to pay so i've tried to
be
more understanding um i think when you
have the
autonomy to do it it's a lot easier
there's no excuse when there's like a
person who's like no family
and just takes it i'm like come on man
but i get it because
he ju and by the way i'm on your psyche
i think he would have done that and he
would have been a hero
and other doors would have been open but
it's a very big risk to ask somebody to
take
who's that established it's true and
i've said this like i understand people
who have kids who are scared to speak
out
but it really sounds like you're betting
the future will be communist wokeness
and so you want to keep your family safe
but if everyone
said no then the future wouldn't be let
me tell you if i
could just maybe one day i might i won't
but like
the a-list celebrities that are in my
inbox that i speak to you would be
shocked
at how many of them hate it i mean it's
all
they are definitely i think the majority
of them hate it right actually the
majority of them hate it and i have
confirmation them on the phone
and i'm just like man you're like top
player in the nba it'd be amazing if you
spoke out like hey you're the number one
i get this one
two r b singer you know and they can't
do it and so they just talk to us
almost like we're like on their
therapist you know or they can just let
it go
i've had people rock stars skateboarders
call me some nearly crying
like i'm scared man you know i could i
could live i
lose everything at a moment i don't know
what to do and i'm like
you're gonna call me and talk to me for
two hours it's like therapy it really is
it is it's they can't care to anybody
they're scared they're terrified they
know they can talk to me because they
watch my show and they trust it and i'm
like
you have how many millions of followers
you could come out right now and just
say guys
i do not think this is okay i think you
need to chill and they're like yeah but
i'll lose everything and i'm like you're
a millionaire
dude i mean that's why kudos to that guy
actually
uh the mumford and sons guy i read his
piece today actually the first time i
read it i think he
released it five days ago and just
saying like i couldn't
you know i knew that i could lose
everything but the same at the end of
the day like my soul wouldn't sit right
if i
allowed this radicalism to be the reason
and he just stepped down from the band
because there's things that are more
important in life and
i think people like him are heroic and
to platform that
i think the more and more people that
kind of inch forward and do it
eventually it'll just be an avalanche
you look at what happens with veritas
you know when someone blows the whistle
and goes to veritas what happened that
facebook guy raised half a million bucks
because there are there are people who
will support you
when you come out and you be brave you
will not be left
holding the bag and i think what james
is doing is incredible because he's
proving it
yeah he's saying be brave and then he's
like and this guy got half a million
dollars
it's true i was just thinking is it
going to take like another jesus or
socrates that speaks the truth
speaks the truth society revolts
executes the person and then 50 or 100
years later we realize
what have we done why what if we this
person was
saying the right thing but no it's not
going to take that because we have
people like james people
it's happening this upsurgence is
happening all at once and people are
making
half a million bucks after the fact so
we've gotten we've evolved
are you are you comparing james o'keefe
to jesus or soccer all of us baby
we all have that in us to speak up
against the empire and that's
if we do it together true it's funny
because i just recently reread plato's
apology
and it's just incredible history repeats
itself and
you know calling out the corruption of
senators and and
the courage that took you know that
there was no upside other than you know
death and and to
and to have it be noble and you know i
hear that same message that was kind of
my mentality when i sort of jumped out
of the window and
you know i know that was kanye's
mentality if you listen to his music i
mean a lot of
the courage that i have is because i
listen to so much kanye west and
to me i i don't have the slave mentality
right so
i'd rather be executed running away
right
towards freedom like i'm definitely the
slave that would have run away from the
plantation i'm the harriet tubman i'm
like you know i'm the kanye west i'm the
you know pick a point in time i'm the
socrates asking people
walking down the street asking them
questions about what they think but
because freedom is natural to me but i
don't know as i was saying
earlier if it's natural for everybody i
i wonder now as i look at this society
and look at copenhagen people that were
like
please lock us down please put us in our
homes please tell me when to see my mom
and dad i'm like
maybe people just want to be enslaved
and this
model of you know slave and master
meaning government and
people that it controls will never be
broken freedom is scary
yeah freedom is dangerous for those of
us that are adults
we're okay with that yeah you know what
i did today i went and i picked a bunch
of wild berries
and then i cooked them and ate them wow
i see that's i got to get on that like
one thing that i i'm definitely lacking
in
is i think it is so important for us to
know how to farm
yeah it's like so important i mean the
amount of control you give up when you
can't
feed yourself yeah is that's like the
next unlock the next layer of the
candace owens game
i want to show and spawn when you pull
the weed out super smooth it's so
rewarding and my last name is farmer
legally oh nice i just got married now
it's even weirder to be like candace
farmer and literally
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you